is gender equality a myth  i don't know what you mean by the  question men and women aren't the same  and they won't be the same that doesn't  mean they can't be treated fairly is  gender equality desirable  if it means equality of outcome then  almost certainly it's undesirable that's  already been demonstrated in scandinavia  because in scandinavia i mean by that  equality of outcome is undesirable well  men and women what i was gonna say let  them explain it  as a women we're not we're not taught  like oh go like work hard at this one  thing and like there are some women that  are taught that but most women aren't  taught go work hard at this one thing  excel at this one thing so once you  reach the the top you can be at the top  and stay at the top and go past all  these people is more so  men that are taught that because  women  children be a mother you say at home mom